hey it's Tom and Jenny from 13 o'clock
this is what we look like in case you
wonder guess what time it is time to do
a patreon we didn't think the show go on
as long as it did but it did and now
it's about time we play kind of the game
if we can move this more to a full-time
production we'll be able to develop and
we'll be able to deliver a lot better
quality show yeah we would like to
upgrade our equipment some and be able
to spend more time focusing on the
research and graphics and you know you
know doing more stuff for this other
channels and maybe expanding into other
channels too in the future if we kind of
get enough of our goal ahead yeah so I
think I think the first goal of 2500
should be that should be reasonable
yeah that's their first kind of Laufey
but I'm pretty confident we can do it
yes and we're going to have three tiers
for you guys if you want to support the
show the first tier is $5 a month and
for that you get access to all our
patreon only posts which will include
pretty much anything we going to put all
kind of extra fun stuff up like many
episodes might be like TV and movie
reviews I might read some short stories
we'll do like behind-the-scenes little
videos and photos and stuff like that
just all kind of fun things like that
whatever we kind of feel like throwing
up there and then if you give $10 a
month then you will get that once you
will get invitations to your monthly
Google Hangouts and our monthly chat on
patreon and then if you give $20 a month
you get all that stuff Plus every few
months we're going to send out some swag
from the show so be t-shirts maybe
postcards autographed books of mine June
I'm broken up and a decade a cutter
cutter Cutlass Becca yeah in fact I
[ __ ] that outside so if you want to
support 13 o'clock and 13 o'clock in
minutes and any other channels we
decided to start at some point the
future is then just click on the little
become our patron but thank you push it
push it real good
[Music]